Maureen is with us in Ontario Canada hi
marine how are you I'm good Dave I'm so
glad you're taking my call sure I have a
quick question today about motivation my
husband and I have finally made the
choice to take control of our finances
and get out of debt we do have a long
road to go and before we can even really
start with the baby steps we have a the
only thing we have to really clear up to
make us current is a 1,000 dollar
overdraft we should be current and have
that out of the way within the next
couple of weeks
great we're already both working two
jobs getting you know everything in
place that you suggest but even doing so
it's going to be probably another two
months before we can start putting
anything extra towards the snowball
we've got other stuff behind yes we
don't have the financial piece
University in Canada don't have that
kind of weekly meeting motivation
that'll just going even though it's
going to be a bit before we actually see
any real progress so I'm wondering what
you know we're putting a name to every
dollar sometimes there's more names and
dollars right now so we're working
towards changing that so if you have any
suggestions to keep us motivated and
stay on track until we finally start
getting into that snowball in the next
six to eight weeks or so yeah absolutely
a couple things
um one what Sharon and I did was we did
two things one was we made a lot of
lists okay and we would mark off those
lists so as long as you feel like you're
getting traction and then the reason you
would feel that way as you are in other
words you've got this thousand dollar
overdraft then you've got some other
bills like electric bill or something
that's behind that you got to get caught
up before you actually start the baby
steps right and make a list of those
things okay and you know mark them off
and make a list of them in priority
house the most important thing we're
going to do then the next thing we're
going to do then the next thing we're
going to do then we're going to get this
current and we're gonna get that current
then our and you know because there are
some sub baby steps that you're taking
before you start the baby steps the
actual ones right right you know just
outline those and and just you know if
you type them up in 24 point or whatever
and put them on the refrigerator and
mark them in a red marker when you get
one and just keep because you are making
progress even though you quote-unquote
haven't started the baby steps yet right
right and you know an example of that is
an example is let me tell you what the
first line on the list is make a plan
I'll feel better okay and you can put a
line through that one okay because you
did didn't you
we did I mean sitting down and seeing
the numbers at first were like who we're
jolting to us but we made the choice to
live this way for the first 28 years of
our marriage and it's time to change
yeah but I mean as soon as you finish
the planning got past the jolt and next
thing that happens is it's like I got
this I got this is exactly right as a
sense of empowerment yeah and so make a
plan and feel the that bad alone gives
you a sense of hey I'm gonna control you
you're not going to control me money
right okay and that there's that's a
breakthrough because it's an emotional
step it's a decision there's that that
thing is happening in your voice it's
like you're going down I hear it in you
know and it's going to take some time
for that to manifest that that's the
first step of getting sick and tired of
being sick and tired and then taking
some steps that are real logical
tactical steps that cause you to start
to win so you already are moving through
that so just acknowledge those things
keep them on the refrigerator we did
that the second thing we did was we
started to measure not only the little
things that we were knocking off okay we
knocked off this $20 thing we knocked
off this $80 thing we knocked off this
120 dollar thing and you just keep
walking down through that like that then
we got caught you know we got current on
the electric that's a big deal it was
for us and then the next thing we did
pass that was we really started taking a
stock of past the little things more of
the big things that we really start
moving the needle on oh great okay and
saying okay we got this thing paid off
and then so a year from now you look
back you go okay we paid off the car I
know it didn't feel like we're getting
very far but think about all those
little things we took care of and then
we paid off the car right and so you
know it starts to be bigger and bigger
chunks that you're knocking off and you
look you know you look to the future for
your motivation but you also look at the
past and see how far we've come that's
true very true and that gives you a
sense of power as well and then lastly
I'm going to sign you up for our to my
Total Money Makeover dot-com okay which
is our subscription-based
outside I'll give it to you though oh
I've got that you don't yes I do that's
when the first things we signed up well
just jump into the forum's yep if
there's none for Canada there is one for
Canada but it's very very my that's nice
an ad in forum pardon me
what is it that you can't access the
forms of no engineer there is a Canadian
oh you know what I'm thinking about the
message boards not the forums oh yeah I
have to navigate around through that and
go jump into the forms because that
they're not they're not germane to a
certain country it's just concepts okay
and it's just people in there supporting
each other going you can do this and you
know don't do that it's stupid okay you
know that they yell at each other in
there it's fun and because there's some
hardcore people in there that are you
know it becomes your support group since
you don't have access to that that's
right okay so use some online support
like that as well
and if you have trouble with that just
call and talk to our our my totally
makeover team and they'll make sure you
get navigated into that and get helped
okay so you can do this Jennifer you're
on your way I can hear the change in
your voice the switch is flipped and
you're ready to attack so just don't let
your foot off the gas just keep pushing
and keep pushing keep pushing keep
pushing you can do it
you